hi
um welcome everyone my name is priyam
vadanatarajan I'm an astrophysicist and
I'm the current director of the Frankie
program in science and the humanities at
Yale our Flagship interdisciplinary
program it's an absolute pleasure and
privilege to invite you all to the
opening event of the Frankie program in
science the humanities for this Academic
Year
I would first like to start by thanking
our generous benefactors Richard and
Barbara Frankie thanks Barbara for
coming today lovely to see you
for their strong support
of interdisciplinary scholarship and
engagement at Yale thanks to their
generous gift we are able to bridge the
so-called two cultures divide and enable
groundbreaking exchange of ideas and
projects that span traditional
disciplinary boundaries
and here is a customary required notice
because we're recording this event that
I'm obliged to read out Yale University
is photographing and videotaping this
event there is a possibility that you
may be included in these visuals by
being present during these activities
you consent to the use of your
appearance likeness and Voice by Yale
University for standard non-profit
educational news related Promotional and
or editorial purposes
okay with that out of the way on to
today's event
we've been hearing a lot about
artificial intelligence
and the power and Perils of the rapid
advances in the field
one of the frontier and open questions
in the field is whether we can build
computer systems platforms maybe even a
robot that can empathize and connect
like we humans do
this Still Remains a challenge
meanwhile we are also finally paying a
lot more attention to animal
intelligence and communicating with them
the wonderful recent film my octopus
teacher demonstrates that there is an
entire unexplored living world out there
under the sea creatures from whom we
have much to learn and understand both
about ourselves and our wonderful Planet
I'm utterly delighted
that Pepa Elric the co-writer director
and editor of my octopus teacher is here
with us today welcome Pepa it's great to
have you here at Yale thank you for
coming
also as per usual will be gathering for
a dinner reception with excellent food
if I may say so myself upstairs in the
fellows Hall immediately after this
event so please do stay on so we're
going to start with the screening of the
film I'll tell you a little bit more
about the film and following that we'll
have a brief q a with an opportunity for
all of you to engage and ask Pippa some
questions the Academy Award winning for
my octopus teacher follows The Story of
the Year Craig Foster spent with a wild
octopus Mr Foster suffering from a loss
of purpose begins a daily diving regimen
in the freezing kelp forest at the tip
of Africa in order to re-energize
himself what he discovers below the
water surface is a totally alien
motivation in the form of an unusually
curious octopus this beautiful record of
an animal's entire life something seldom
achieved in the wild let alone
underwater was shot over an entire year
and explores the habits and personality
of a strange undulating creature that
most of us well not all of us have only
ever eaten filmed with The Cutting Edge
6K cameras some of the world's top
filmmakers cinematographers and
scientists came together to create this
incredibly remarkable film which marks
the First underwater movie combining
high-end Blue Chip Natural History
sequences with the story of a human
animal relationship documenting the
individual creature throughout its
lifetime in the wild the film has of
course garnered a great amount of
attention from conservationists
scientists all over the world as well as
celebrities and it has received more
than 20 International Awards including
an Oscar a bafta the prestigious wild
screen Golden Panda Jackson's Wilds
Grand Teton award the ideas Paris Lorenz
and the producers Guild of America award
for the best documentary motion picture
for the last six years Peppa has been
part of the sea change project exploring
the underwater 4 of Cape Town prior to
joining sea change Pippa worked as an
environmental journalist specializing in
the field of Marine Science and
conservation and the intersection
between people in the natural world she
has worked with some of the world's top
Marine researchers and underwater
photographers and has been an avid free
diver herself for more than a decade so
um I am
delighted before that I would like to
give a super special thank you to two
people who worked really extra hard to
pull this evening's event together
Tony sudol our av Wiz who worked very
hard to secure the proper screening
platform for today's event his
professional expertise has made this
event possible and he actually helps us
with all our events and he worked long
hours and weekends to procure the film
and to actually do the test run
uh Tony I'm deeply grateful to you for
your commitment
and I have to call out
Dr Ty Camp without whom much of what we
do in the Frankie program would not be
possible thank you so much Tai for
everything that you do
[Applause]
we announce some of upcoming events so
we have a pointer fellow
journalist writer who writes for the New
Yorker magazine parole Segal who will be
visiting this semester we have Talks by
Professor Meredith Broussard and Kathy
O'Neill both of whom are investigating
the ways in which big data and
Technology are reinforcing race and
gender inequality we are still waiting
for the dates to be announced so keep an
eye out and on December 14th and 15th we
are organizing our annual nature of
inference conference that will draw
close to that long-term project that
we've been doing anyway without further
Ado let me turn over to the screen so
that we can all watch my octopus teacher
thank you so much to all of you for
coming
[Applause]
so um I was curious how long it actually
took for you guys to edit it down and
bring it to this form
um forever
and it's it's I haven't seen this film
in two years now and I was this is the
first time I've ever seen it in a movie
theater
what are you serious what because we've
all seen it on Netflix on our laptops or
computers
you had it
covered all right right okay the film
came out during covert so yeah it was it
was pretty amazing actually to see it
with an audience
oh wow oh we feel really honored
in terms of how long it took so
for Craig it was obviously a much longer
journey I mean by the time I met him
he'd been diving every day for six or
seven years already the octopus was had
died already
um
and what that meant was there was an
awful lot of footage
so the first three months was just
looking at what we had so that we could
start to figure out exactly where our
story was going to focus
um and then it was
three years of editing
so I imagine so that's why I started off
with this question because it has to
have been a gargantuan job of getting it
but it was it's beautifully done it
looks so gorgeous on a large screen and
very moving I don't know somehow it felt
much more moving on the large screen
I had to hold back tears as well
but um I um I would like to open it up
to questions from the audience I have a
couple of my own but I'll hold back so I
see an arm go up promptly and so we have
a roving mic
so yeah
yeah
my voice is loud so I think you've
probably been here but I will also
project through this um
first congratulations on the film
obviously it's been very very Accolade
it's got many accolades and very well
awarded and very well deserved and I'm
sure you've heard that a million times
so
pure labor that but I um I I wanted to
know
when he says you were a visitor and
we're not just a visitor we're a part of
this
did you ever feel like there's Craig or
did he even feel or relate to you that
you know I feel like I'm encroaching on
their space and I'm changing how they
made the camera made I'm an actor so the
camera can't always changes the way you
look
it's just natural so it would change the
behaviors of the different Wildlife that
you were coming into interaction with
and is that something that you were
cognizant of or is that something that
you
got more comfortable with if that's at
all possible or is it just was it a
daily struggle maybe just to
I mean I think
these are things where you're evolving
all the time uh as an as an individual
and as a Storyteller
um and it was something that I was very
conscious of the whole time because I'd
come from a very scientific journalistic
place where engaging with animals like
this was actually completely alien
to me
um but when I started diving with Craig
and seeing how he engaged with animals
and seeing how animals actually
approached him
many of these creatures
they don't have to be there he's not
going to go and kind of chase them down
um
and I guess my
attitude started to change slightly and
I still I think it's very very complex I
think you do change their behavior
I think in some cases it's negative in
some cases it's not because they're as
curious as you are
and with most creatures that live
underwater they can swim and move a lot
better
in the Ocean than we can
um
but I what I'm increasingly conscious of
is what kind of message are you putting
out because Craig is incredibly
experienced respectful
and kind of loving towards these animals
but I don't know if you can always
expect everyone to go into natural
spaces like that and more and more in
our work because I still work with sea
change project
um
I'm not sure today if we would make a
film like this because we've seen so
much more and
but that's it I think I think that
separating people from nature is where
all the problems have started anyway
again just for the
what because I
I think it is complicated how close
should we be getting to the natural
world
um so do you feel like the negatives
outweigh the positives no after doing it
no no not at all because I didn't feel
real that the negatives are real because
you are perturbing
you know their life cycle you're
intervening in a way that you know it's
not entirely clear if you're welcome
right so it's an intervention but you
would say the same thing about putting
tags on shocks or putting tags on baby
turtles or any kind of biological study
and if we don't do those things how are
we going to learn anything
so I would say the positives far
outweighed the negatives
then why wouldn't you do something like
this again because I've done it
I thought you meant in terms of just
like the that you felt that there was
more negative message
maybe social media wise or anything I
mean we got a lot of criticism of course
and we expected that I mean
my next film is also about a
relationship with between a human and an
animal but that animal's being
rehabilitated so
that engagement is inevitable so it's a
slightly different situation but
it's just just tricky I mean of course
well it sounds like the next project is
something where there's a restoration
for the animal right you're trying to
restore it back to its original place in
the wild yeah
you want to run everything
okay
um it's for the recording that we would
like to have the mic to throw it you can
actually catch it it's a soft box
oh that's why it's called catch box
now I got it now yeah I could I didn't
get it for the longest time
um thank you so much for for being here
and that was wonderful it was my first
time seeing it on the big screen but not
my first time seeing it
um I wanted to actually ask about
freediving
um you know as opposed to diving in
general like being a scuba diver and
somebody who works on on reefs in
particular
um I find free diving almost at this
really
um funny and strange activity this is a
strangely dangerous
um but also like very particular like
people who do it it the you know those
who have met
um don't see it as a dangerous activity
which is always something that's
surprised to me and and and continues to
um so in your work with sea change and
also you know you work with Craig and
stuff like that how have you sort of
come to think about diving culture and
free diving's place in it as you know as
as part of a world where I think you
know we rely on on tanks so much or
snorkels or this or that or like you
know the shallow versus the Deep you
know how do we
think about diving culture you know writ
large through
pre-diving which you know yeah
um
I mean we dive to engage with the
natural world and to find things out and
to take photographs uh
I've never really and I would actually
like to but I've never got into
freediving as an adrenaline sport which
it obviously is in a massive way if
anyone's seen the deepest breath
um
it's just an incredible way to explore
things underwater and
you can go anywhere free diving you can
hike to a bit of like completely
unexplored kelp forest that's an hour
away of any way you can get your car
and all you need is a mask and a snorkel
and some fins and a camera
you would never be able to get there
with scuba gear without a boat
so
and the other thing that's been
incredible in Cape Town which was partly
due to covert and partly due to the film
and partly just due to a growing
underwater Community is freediving has
become a massive massive thing in Cape
Town
and diving without wetsuits has become a
massive thing and in a country where
access to Nature
is not Democratic at all
and you've got a massive massive gap
between poor people and wealthy people
being able to engage with nature in this
way without having to have loads and
loads of expensive equipment
is pretty revolutionary
there's our next question is here
oh I think
[Music]
um thank you so much I've never seen the
film before on the small or large screen
so it was beautiful um
and I had a question for you sort of you
were talking about the narrative and
editing and I was hoping you could speak
a little bit to the role of gender in
the film because obviously this is a
female octopus that's revealed at the
end when she gives birth but I noticed
the entire time Craig sort of refers to
her as she and I think it's sort of
interesting because you have this
imposition of a very sort of human idea
and almost I sensed a bit of almost a
kind of like at times paternal at times
romantic way that he's framing this
relationship which I think really does
add something to the film but perhaps at
the cost of imposing as I said a sort of
human idea of gender or of relations
onto
these animals so I'm just curious if you
could talk a little bit more about the
positives and negatives or anything you
want to say about he wasn't going to
call the octopus it I mean in no
Universe you can see
the kind of respect and
reverence he has for that animal he was
never gonna say it did this and it did
that
and she was dead you know two or three
years before we did the interview so
she'd always known that he'd always
known that that she was a female
so I mean were we imposing anything I
think we would just
telling a story where the animal
happened to be female
um
what does it mean
I'm not sure I think
if the octopus had been male and there
hadn't been this kind of story of
motherhood
we would have ended up with a very very
kind of masculine film so I think that
we were actually really lucky
that the feminine octopus of the energy
of the octopus was there to balance out
this other very strong father-son
narrative
which went through the film and you know
again that that wasn't a creative Choice
Craig just happened to have a boy not a
girl
just to be clear I didn't mean in the
sense of like a dehumanizing effect but
more just I think we're trying to think
in binauristic different ways about
gender and what that means and the
relationship between sex and gender so
more in that sense but yeah thank you
very interesting
this question and then
oh God
thank you
hi um thank you for hosting this event
and thank you for coming and this is my
first time watching the film and I was
so impressed by how perfectly crafted
The Narrative sequences were and like
those Chase sequences were almost they
reminded me of the French Connection and
how well crafted they were and all these
like shot River shots between the
octopus and Craig I I'm wondering more
like from a technical perspective how
much was shot after the fact and how
much was Greg's original footage yeah so
pretty much anytime you see Craig
without the octopus
that was filmed later
um what was quite amazing in certainly
the chase sequences and many of the
hunting sequences
Craig was on one camera and Roger
harrix's friend who shot most of the
underwater was on a red so that's how
you have those reverse angles
you've got Craig with his little tiny
handicam like racing around and Roger on
his big raid setup
fantastic given that there was no shadow
I was looking really hard to see I mean
is there who's the filmer right where's
the shadow I saw a shadow once which I'd
never noticed before I only saw it
tonight because of the big screen
it was a flash yeah I didn't see it yeah
let's see I definitely didn't catch it
so I did the same a similar thing this
summer with deer family of deer that
we're out where I used to run not here
in Connecticut but I would go back every
day
I found that in watching them and how
they react to me
I started
seeing more instinctual
Behavior by humans particularly how we
look at or regard strangers who are
coming at us
and the whole Predator prey thing and
that sort of thing and so I'm wondering
if he
[Music]
um
his experience with those animals had
resulted in him
gaining Insight on human beings
and how instinctual we are
very much sir yeah
um I think
I think during this time and I see Craig
do it with other animals now
anyone who understands animals well is
doing this all the time and you you're
constantly moving out of human mind into
animal mind as best you can
because we are humans and that's the
framework through which we understand
the world but
and there's a lot of criticism about
anthropomorphism but the truth is that
every single living thing on this planet
wants to live and there's the stachotomy
between life or death and that means
that we've gained all of these instincts
and in the human world those instincts
have translated into emotions
But ultimately it's the same kind of
physiological driving forces that are
making us feel these things so
I get quite frustrated when people say
things like you know an octopus can't
feel emotions because why we think
our emotions which are really just
survival instincts
are above what an animal experiences
is really just extremely arrogant
in terms of him not wanting to intervene
between the the shark it's almost like
I it's like he's almost like well I'm in
the position of God here
no I thought it was very self-conscious
because he said I shouldn't intervene in
nature the order but if he's part of
this is my point if he's part of nature
if he's in there if he's not a guest if
he's if he's in it then him intervening
in that he's part of the system
out of the natural order of the system
right well I think he's not his habitat
I think he is so but he's in there he's
swimming
that's natural
I mean I think if you
this is this was the biggest thing I was
kind of confused about well while making
the film and
that that was the choice he made it's
not necessarily the choice I would have
made and and I found it confusing okay
well you're not going to save it from
the shark
but you think it's okay to feed it
muscles right
feed her muscles
um
and for Craig it makes sense and I think
that's what we do as humans you know
some of us say well I'm not going to eat
octopus because I saw this amazing movie
but I'm going to keep eating lamb and
chicken and cows exactly and we are all
making these personal decisions that
feel right to us and they are
hypocritical and they don't make perfect
sense yeah and they're often
contradictory right I mean I'm a
vegetarian and I would not eat any have
not eaten any animal knowingly but I
have squashed ants right I mean I do I
mean I mean I'm more gentle with spiders
I ask them to leave and I gently you
know but ants I'm always squishing
mosquitoes
I've never been lucky in squatting any
of them or supporting any of them
but I think okay we will close with one
fine okay maybe two final questions
because I don't want to keep you much
longer from the yummy food that we have
upstairs
Stephen yeah all right
thank you what a it's a really
extraordinary movie my second time
viewing it but and seeing it on a big
screen really
um amplifies so much of the incredible
messaging that you've created I think in
this film one of the things that sticks
with me is um is consciousness is is how
this film and I and I think things that
really change our perception of the
world is is the way we see it and I
think um
one of the things that I was struck with
was early in the film the way you set it
up
um with his trip to Africa and
acknowledging that these guys were
seeing things differently than he could
ever see them and all he there was a
sense of like he wanted that he wanted
to have that depth of connection
do you feel that um in making this film
and I know you had your your background
in
um The Sciences were you did you find
your perception your Consciousness has
changed towards nature just in the
process of making the film
absolutely
just
making this film I was spending two
three hours a day underwater with those
animals
and even without an indigenous lens
which is something that I'm very very
interested in now and exploring very
deeply
um just spending that much time
surrounded by nature in that way and
kind of putting yourself at the mercy of
it at the mercy of big waves big sharks
currents
um
that completely changes you
and yeah it just
in some ways Things become much simpler
but then in other ways more complex I
suppose
yeah I can imagine that it makes you
feel vulnerable and yet stronger somehow
because you kind of survive every time
you go and you come back out
successfully right maybe I can only
imagine
there's one final question before we
close let me just pass them
thank you
um thank you so much for being here
thank you so much for the film
um this is probably a bad last question
but I was wondering like could you talk
about like the Genesis of the project
like how you found the story or how the
story found you maybe
so it's quite a long story but I'm gonna
try and I'm gonna speed it up
um
I was working as a conservation
journalist for a meet marine
conservation NGO
and
I was speaking to all these incredible
scientists all over the world and I was
hearing their stories of
how they were working with these animals
and immersing in environments and having
these magical experiences
and two things happened number one I
became a little bit frustrated that they
would tell me these things on a call
but if ever it was an interview or I
asked them to write a blog or anything
else they took all the emotion out of
everything that they wrote
and I found as someone who was really
trying to make a difference in the world
and bring the natural world to life
I was like if the people who are closest
to Nature are unwilling to talk about
how they really feel about nature what
chance do we stand
so that was the first thing
and the second thing was I started
feeling like I was
vicariously experiencing all these
things
and I desperately wanted to have my own
connection
to the Natural World
um and Craig was doing talks all over
Cape Town
not about the octopus but just about the
kelp forest in general
and I ended up going diving with him
through a mutual friend
um
and yeah I bought six months later we've
done a couple of small projects together
and and he asked if I would like to help
him make the film and at that point I
really thought I would just be carrying
a tripod
that's I did not expect it to evolve the
way that it did on any level
fantastic thank you so much for coming
and
[Applause]
foreign